you think you can take me to nowhere
land of my world that's what I think now
I think it's my world I know I know
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we close out season 20 with Jake
Gyllenhaal he's an academy
award-nominated actor whose resume
includes everything from box office
shattering franchise films to chilling
psychological thrillers to West End
Productions in the Broadway stage his
latest project though is the guy Richie
directed action thriller of the Covenant
which is set to release in theaters on
April 21st Jake Gyllenhaal welcome to
the show it is an honor to be here thank
you for having me I know that you're
fully committed to your prep work as an
actor yeah did you do anything to
prepare for today's hot ones interview
the preparation came from just being
constantly battered by you guys for a
number of years which has been actually
really flattering honestly and um and
then um also the people some people that
I work with telling me that they
wouldn't work for me anymore if I didn't
come so I am nothing without them and I
need to be here for that reason only so
well thank you guys so much for the
referral thank you guys so much for the
referral Jake you ready to get started
uh no laughs
[Music]
you're eating with your fingers that's
interesting a little pull oh look at how
that service you are yeah yeah that's
interesting I see that
I I should have I should have seen that
another
this is not a competition it's just
[Music]
that wasn't so bad
like really good
so the Covenant tells the story of a U.S
army Sergeant and Afghan interpreter who
become bonded more or less out of
necessity in the wake of an ambush that
puts them both in a unique position to
save each other and Guy Richie I
understand that part of his approach to
filmmaking is to give an actor a lot of
space to explore did you find that to be
more daunting more challenging or more
liberating in a film that's otherwise so
Technical and intense I love I the thing
I love about my job is that you get to
work with so many different
um Minds you know and particularly
people at the helm they're all different
and with guy it was unlike anything I've
ever done he said to me don't memorize
any of your lines and the script came in
50 pages it wasn't a fully written
script usually scripts are like 110
pages and I was like what is this when
he first sent it and he said you come to
set we'll work on it on the day and
you'll go shoot your thing
and it was one of the most inspiring
creative experiences I've ever had
because it asked for total let go you
know just let go come in figure it out
figure it out together
um I loved it I loved it
[Music]
why are you looking at me like that well
you're not the only one observing you
have that right do it like this
[Laughter]
get used to it get used to it as we go
here I've noticed it yeah you have one
hell of an upper body oh like yeah thank
you I'm never really seen your lower
body move but your upper body is sort of
extraordinary yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
sort of amazing yeah it's really amazing
there's unlike anything of it like I
don't think I've ever seen it might like
anything you've ever seen the clue to
like the hit of the show oh it's just
like how weird you right right the
center of gravity being like um you know
like outside of a car dealership when
they have the inflatable things yeah
yeah that is the magic of hot ones by
the way one of my favorite shots in the
movie I've been is a shot of one of
those inflatable things in a montage
when it does it so you're like that
that's why you're my favorite I take
that as a cop Yeah man
so I heard you said that you started off
relying on sheer Talent no technique and
that you learn how to be a good actor by
working with great directors on set do
you think that a conflict between an
actor and director can yield special
results or is that one of those things
that works best a relationship that
works best when everyone's on the same
wavelength sometimes sometimes I'll come
to a film and I'm just in someone's
world and I'm doing my job I am an actor
for hire and I've done the work on my
character and my character alone and
it's their world to build and I'll just
do that job
and try and do it better than they
expected and then sometimes
you have a connection with someone
I believe
the best stuff is when we're most
vulnerable I've experienced that very
rarely where I trust somebody so much
they can literally take me anywhere and
I'll go and I open up to them
um and the weird part of that is
sometimes it's not always they're not
always the best movies I've made so I
it's it's it's it's a it's a mystery
after however many movies it's I still
don't know
yeah it does look like Donnie dark yeah
it looks like Frank
wait no wait hold up
a little rip right yeah yeah grip it and
rip it this is I think that's just part
of the technique because you got to save
your lips right
when you put your 10 000 hours in yeah
yeah save your lips okay
oh if at all would you say your
experience doing theater has changed or
influenced your approach to making
movies
oh I got a creepy booger hot sauce yeah
yeah you do you know when someone's like
and they're just talking like this yeah
do you think if I was talking about this
I didn't know the only thing people
would pay attention to is this I think
it is yeah I think so speaking of
theater yeah yeah yeah I've seen actors
steal scenes on stage like that really
yeah yeah just like come in and like put
something on a table and they leave and
it's like precarious and the whole
audience looks at the thing that the
other actor coming in this is a
technique I'm using it that's disgusting
that's not hot sauce I actually that's
those are my boogers
so it's all about the story in theater
I'm saying I always believe it's always
about the story like story is King
you you start to realize like in a
rehearsal for instance as an example
like one time
I got yeah it's a little hot that's a
little hot
um I I enter her so once
I don't know if it's hot or if it's
everyone being like is it hot for him
the vibes
oh really you don't feel that yeah sure
you don't feel that everything okay Jake
there's nothing weirder than that you
okay if anyone asks you that you're like
no I'm not am I I'm clearly not okay uh
but uh there's a moment in
in rehearsal where it was a moment in
rehearsal where we were in previews
which is when the audience comes you
know but you're not open yet so you're
testing the play out in front of
audiences but you're tweaking things
before the review reviewers come
and I remember a director coming to me
and an actor that I was working with and
we thought we killed it that night like
we were like oh my God we're both so
emotional and like because you were
amazing and like you were amazing like
she came back the direction was like
that was so slow and so boring you need
to pick it up we were like what that was
the best thing we've ever done she was
like it was the worst one I've seen
she's like just pick it up for tomorrow
night the next night we came in we just
set our lines we paced it up and we did
it she came back crying
crying she was like that was incredible
and you're like what and all we did was
tell the story
we all we did was say the lines we kept
the Rhythm right the mind of the
audience was following along and so they
were allowed to be moved and it just
allows you to be more present in every
form of acting that makes any sense I'm
following right along I like uh I like
diving into the abstract right along
welcome to my world in this deep well
Welcome to our world you know this black
Vortex where we can just
what time it's no it's no time it's no
time
[Music]
did you just blow on it
yeah now I'm changing I'm gonna oh
angles yeah I'm going angles
take my lips away oh [__] almost dropped
that
of all the characters you've played
which one did you say had the biggest
transformation or Evolution from the way
that it was written into the script to
what ultimately ended up materializing
on screen
I think about a character like that I
played
in a movie called prisoners
um awesome movie thanks
um and the character was written one way
but I could see the essence of something
else in it in the first draft it was a
character that was much more kind of
straight laced he was much more sort of
trying to find an answer but they're
trying to find the answer thing was the
most interesting part of it and I don't
think that outward strappings of it
trappings of it were were as important
but to me they became important and I
wanted the character to be a mystery
like but determined so the audience had
two things going on at the same time and
so to me it's not necessarily like
a bad script that became a good movie
but sometimes you just add on to things
you know and they become something
totally different than what was written
on the page but still with the same
intention you know
um
then again I think Bubble Boy was a
a pretty good script and a fantastic
movie so
um so I guess that sort of that's that's
my answer
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
I immediately feel on my lips
um
what's that okay now it's getting hotter
yeah yeah and it lives a little bit oh
great you know like it grows a little
bit thanks bro for that information
after you know I'm just you know this is
this is me being honest yeah you know
when people hold information and then
they give it to you afterwards right
that's not really honesty just FYI but
um that's cool I'm we're in nowhere land
so I guess that's the way that's how it
goes that's how it goes we're in the
abstract
determined not to unfold this napkin and
just wipe slowly oh I like that all
right I am so determined I have watched
you by the way like I you're sometimes
much more interesting to watch than the
guests don't even think about it on this
one but the
but I know it's really it's it's it I
there's a lot of I'm looking right back
I'm looking right back in your soul all
right Jake
I like this it sucks though because like
you don't get to come back do you oh
yeah people come back posts came back
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you want to come back Jake open invite
wait a second I'm just I'm enjoying
myself now yeah yeah let's see how it
goes okay
is it true that the chasing and End of
Watch in your patrol car smashes into
the back of a silver minivan that that
wasn't scripted that the production had
pulled out the anti-lock brake system
because it made the mounted camera move
wow damn
[Music]
um it wasn't a mistake as all stunts go
you never really know how it's gonna go
any good stunt is a little bit of a
mistake all right we all were so jacked
about that opening sequence you know we
come out of the car and there's all this
live fire you know we approach and you
meet the characters for the first time
it was all meant to be one take so we
were just when we got it we were like
did we get it we got it everyone was so
excited so it was fun fact or fiction
that scene in Nightcrawler where you're
yelling at yourself in the mirror you
got so caught up in the improvisation
that you ended up cutting your hand open
four hour operation 46 stitches four
hours no I wasn't like put on under
anything but yeah yeah I did I got
stitches yeah 46 stitches fun fact the
opening of that movie if anyone gives a
[__] that movie kicks ass thank you yeah
yeah we should the opening the movie you
meet my character my hands are behind my
back
um through the opening
uh
two or three scenes we shot those scenes
last
um and because I had a huge cast on my
arm
my entire character my I'm hiding we're
hiding it throughout those
fact or fiction the burning latrines and
Jarhead had real human and animal feces
as a way to give you like a real
authentic reaction in the scene
um that is uh not true
a fact I mean false that's false that is
false I was not there was no real [__]
in that
um but what they did do sorry what they
did do was they put [__] flies in it
to make it look like real [__] they had
a fly
uh what is it Wrangler
I didn't even know that such a thing
exactly a dude with flies came with like
all these flies and then would in the
fake [__] would like rub sweet stuff all
over it and then throw and then also
I've had that happen in movies where
they they throw flies at your face to
make them look like you know like if
you're like playing dead or something
that the Flies are flying on you and
they have fly Wranglers and they come
over and they like Drop flies on your
face and try and put sugar on your face
and stuff so they fly stay sometimes
they just have like flies on your face
just when you're sitting there like
waiting for them like we're rolling uh
no can you get the fly the fly's not
moving on his face
you know so yeah oh I just touched my
face I know oh okay anyway
[Music]
that feels hot now it's in my whole
mouth
this is like have you ever seen that
that Danny K movie
um the court jester
no no no put me on game okay
um because there's a piece in that
there's like it has a rhyming scheme in
it where he's like the Chalice with the
palace has the brew that is true but the
vessel with the pestle as he like does
this whole thing it's like a word game
that's what I feel about this because
one of them like has poison in it do you
know what I mean it looks like so good
to drink right you know what I mean and
you're like don't [__] with the water
yeah all right yeah well then we'll stay
off we'll stay off the liquids all right
cool we'll see how it goes
so coming out of Oscar season you hear
all these Hollywood pundits talking
about breakout stars and
[Laughter]
their next move will be they obsess
about the sequence of roles and this
person needs a Prestige film next this
person needs a blockbuster is that
advice that you would give to a young
actor or was there ever a time in your
career where you felt that kind of
pressure oh my God yes we're gonna get
deep for a second yeah let's do it okay
let's do it but when you see like
I was I had the honor and have had the
honor twice in my life to go see
Michelangelo's David in Italy right and
when you see his David I am not
comparing my career to Michelangelo when
you see his David and you see how much
effort he put into that like every
single it's polished every single detail
it's like a scientific work of magic and
also Perfection it's an artistic work of
the same thing you know it's insane but
right next to it in the museum are the
slaves you have half form figures you
didn't even finish chipping them out of
the marble right and their works of
genius and so I think like early in a
career you think I have to make it all
like everyone you know and then slowly
you just start to go like this is
interesting I'm gonna try that what's my
what do I want to do like how do I want
to express myself and like
sometimes for me personally that's been
about like oh let's have fun like
whatever [__] it you know and sometimes
it's been like this moves me so deeply
that I cannot tell
so yes I mean that's I think that's
inevitable that part I've been through
it and I've made choices I'm proud of
and
other ones I'm not but it's all part of
the game and you just gotta stay in it
mermaids so so they should hit
oh
this left a stain this one that is
staying on the wood this is an orange
stain on the wood yeah it's that time
it's that time in the lineup oh yeah
how's it back in the throat yeah
that's cool
you guys have like two picks with people
and stuff yeah we do is that post you
know actually we keep it around just in
case you need anything people aren't
allowed to wet ones then you think about
one you can wet one no way not for
yourself [__] wet ones who [__]
used Wet Ones what is that [__] that
[__] that [__] that what [__] used to
[__] use a toothpick
who is Elizabeth Olsen oh sorry
Elizabeth
she's like like about literally the
least [__] I've ever met so I'm sorry
walk that one back all right absolutely
I'm walking that back I'll give me 14 of
the above I'm sorry
which was a more uncomfortable character
development exercise simulating altitude
sickness in a hyperbaric chamber to
prepare for Everest whoa you've really
beautiful searching I guess or or
getting tased in the lead up for your
role as an LA cop an End of Watch
the altitude training lingered for at
least a day I mean talk about an
experience that like made me feel like
my brain had exploded because we went
basically up to 36 000 feet and then we
were like Josh Brolin and I were like
dancing in the chamber like we're fine
and we got out and we're like and we
were laughing and laughing and laughing
and we got out and like when we got out
we were both like do you feel strange
and like both of us were like and we
fell asleep and we woke up and I was
like who are you he's like Josh Brolin I
was like what the [__] like it was so
weird well at least it was with Josh
Brolin you know that actually sounds
like a fun guy to go through something
like that
total blast but I think I lost a number
of brain cells which is how I'm getting
through this today so well you know what
for this next sauce the fewer the brain
cells the better
this is the bomb Beyond insanity
this one is wild
see this is me talking now you know I
could kind of tell the other ones now
you're [__] me up now I'm telling you
before though you know this is honesty
I'm telling you before thank you
that's how a relationship evolves so I
really go through the wings yeah yeah
oh God but it'll probably take a step
back after this bite [__]
it smells like a barbecue like it smells
like
but
oh God
three two
yes yeah oh when I swallow too yeah yeah
right right right right right
yeah that's I mean
it's really making me make a lot of
saliva right yeah yeah that's the ways
that it kind of like physiologically
changes you my body's like this is
poison and you yeah right like once like
reject I think my leg just cramped
oh don't breathe in yeah I know like
breathing makes it worse everything
makes it worse
I love you man I love you right back I
love you right like I'm taking this
moment and I just want to know you
you're taking me somewhere very special
and I want to say I love you and you're
and you know what there's love all
around all around all no matter what
happens
well I appreciate it because you know
when our when the when the relationship
was evolved
oh my God
I think I need to eat the whole thing
all right before you do yeah
I can't lift the wing I'm cramping
right bro
here we go I'll see you on the other
side
oh I'm really trying to get in my eyes
either I just fear that it's gonna pop
yeah
oh God lord
if I'm here I'm [__] done this man I
like that I like that I'm I'm like fully
immersed in the experience
incredible [__] this
I hate this
oh yeah
I look like more man I love you even I
love you even more same Jake rise up
this is beautiful
oh my God
okay so Ryan Reynolds once called you a
black belt in the kitchen I've heard you
talk about spending the better part of
the day shopping on Fresh Direct what is
it that you find
oh [__] did you ask these questions I
didn't get these things how do you know
I spend so much time on Fresh Direct
what is it that you find so special or
otherworldly about the River Cafe in
London
slow cooked tomato sauce
what I find so special about it
Simplicity
um
oh wow you drank water
I have the most electric head high right
now off of this than I've ever had doing
really yeah want to know why because now
you're in my world that's not great I
brought you into my world now
you think you can do it I know where you
landed in my world that's what I think
now I think it's my world I know I know
I am in nowhere land right now I am
floating I am floating oh my God
it's coming down a little bit but I feel
like I have just beautiful lips right
now yeah
that can't be stopped
respect [__] yourself
[Music]
this is great
[Laughter]
it is great really no no no I hate this
sauce yeah but this is great yeah yeah
you're awesome oh I understand why
people really dig you man you're awesome
it was really fun oh well thank you Jake
I hate you so much all right I know I
know I don't hate you I really don't but
I'm not every time I breathe in yeah or
when you think you're like out of it
yeah yeah right it pulls you back in
pulls you back in
[Laughter]
can you give us one highlight and one
low light from the time that you spent
exploring the Frozen Wilderness of
Iceland alongside Bear Grylls oh yeah
well one of the highlights which is
being there like being in Iceland with
Bear Grylls like doing the adventure
taking the challenge like that was like
that was just so cool and I think the of
of everything we did
um being hooked up to a harness
oh god without knowing it
then being connected to a helicopter and
being flown across Iceland hanging
dangling from a helicopter was a
highlight the not fun part was when they
asked me on a question here
I should have known what are you most
afraid of and I said like I really would
love to not do things but things that
were too high like heights yeah
and then the last challenge was me
having to drag myself across a line like
a like a rope with a 1500 foot drop like
from like with you know like I don't
know it's two football fields long their
bear was like wow we can't we in order
to finish this whole day we or this
whole challenge we have to crawl across
things like I told you I was afraid of
heights he's like well like he's like we
can take the other walk around which
takes seven days and I was like what the
[__] and I was like I told you I was
afraid of heights
and we and we and we and and I did that
that was the low that sucked like that
was like I was in the middle of this
rope the wind was flailing like it was
snowing and I was wrapped my left no
[__] my leg was wrapped around a rope
and that was yanking myself laying on a
rope across this thing and the Rope was
just flying back and forth in the wind
and there was Bear Grylls going like you
can do it mate like that
I was like uh that was a look that was a
low point that was a low point so yeah
but you made it through but you made it
through I didn't made it through oh yeah
[Laughter]
are you dab when I dab
kind of just pouring it all over but
don't do that but okay fine
no
no good no what I when you said
that whatever season 20 you gotta do it
big all right I'm just trying to match
you is this like made out of the ashes
of your past guests
we collect them after they put them in
the entire Legacy of the show yeah it's
just it's all in here kind of think of
it I haven't seen any of them after
these interviews
all right
yeah right right
oh I know I know wizard hands
oh
insane [__] it insane I'm [__] it we
hear you got to do it season 20 go out
[__] the [__] Bang Yeah
you guys didn't do 20 Seasons to watch
me take a little mini bite out of this
[__] thing
[Music]
wait that
and Jake Gyllenhaal mercifully that's a
wrap on hot ones season 20. that's a
wrap on the wings of death then to close
things up I'm fascinated by this quote
of yours there's strange idiosyncrasies
from roles that I play that I picked up
that will never go away can you think of
an example of something that you picked
up on for a role that's still in your
DNA and then follow-up is there a
peculiarity a tick that you think you
might carry with you after going through
this experience
[Music]
truly in my life uh at the age I'm at I
was like if there's something that I'm
afraid of and I'm thinking about why I'm
afraid of it a lot of times I want to go
try and do it and you guys have actually
asked me a few times to do it and I will
admit here that I've probably been a
little bit afraid to do it and um I'm at
a different point in my life where I'm
just like you know what let's go because
this was this was great like I I burst
through like a little thing that I was
uh not a little thing I think that I was
a little bit nervous about
true and I appreciate that I'm grateful
to you for that and man there's just
there's nothing but love like and all
those people who said that I hate you
while they eat These Wings [__] that
[__] them I got your back [__] up I
got your back [__] them you heard Jake
Gyllenhaal and that is a flag in to the
ground for season 20 taking on the wings
of death living to tell the tale no milk
no milk no no milk the entire water
right once me like three or four but
who's counting this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life I have
literally nothing going on I have no
friends does anybody want to hang out
now thank you so much for having me
thank you so much
thanks guys you did it that was fun man
thank you so much thank you man you did
so good
this episode's gonna be so [__] good
oh good
thank you thank you man yeah it's all
good that was really fun you've had a
good time yeah so much fun
I love it I love it like I like pull out
one of those pull out one of those um
hot hot like how hot can you go yeah
yeah yeah well that's the Carolina
Reaper that's that's as high as it goes
it's it's a it's like genetically
designed to be that hot
ones fans exciting news the season 20
hot ones 10 pack is now available if
you've ever watched from home and
wondered to yourself how hard are the
wings really or been one of those people
that's like oh I've only taken one bite
well you know what if you think you can
do better now is the time to put your
money where your mouth is literally with
the hot ones season 20 10 pack available
exclusively at heatness.com that's
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 20 hot
ones 10 pack
[Music]
get them while they're high
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]